was sagen sie denn jetzt ist jan sparen
ganz gut drauf er hat leichte
erkältungssymptome spricht das dafür
dass die krankheit jetzt auch mild
verläuft also man muss so sagen man muss
jetzt erstmal vier bis acht tage
abwarten entwickelt sich dass die
kritische zeit ist etwa der siebte bis
elfte tag dort entscheidet sich das ob
der patient noch weiter beschwerden
bekommt oder vielleicht sogar intensiv
richtig wird wir in unserer region
beziehungsweise hat patienten war das so
auch nach dem fünften sechsten tag wurde
es kritisch
aber ich selber kenne jens spahn hatte
mit einer veranstaltung mit ebenfalls
vier wochen
er hat wirklich dort auch diese
veranstaltung auch wie immer sehr
penibel die ganzen regeln eingehalten
und das ist ehrlich gesagt was mir mehr
gedanken und sorgen macht dass jemand
der wirklich sehr im thema drin ist er
sich wirklich auch sehr daran hält und
sehr bemüht ist er daran erkrankt das
macht mich wirklich sehr nachdenklich
meines erachtens ist es so dass sich
dieses ganze kabinett testen lassen
müsste und in quarantäne weil wie gesagt
auch wenn diese abstände da sind da
gewesen sind aber man muss auch mal mit
gutem vorbild vorangehen und zweitens
wir wissen nicht wie die ansteckung
erfolgte und man muss vorsichtig sein
und wir können wir uns nicht erlauben
gerade in dieser kritischen zeit dass
irgendwann weil so ein hotspot in
unserem bundeskabinett praktisch
explodiert